hello everyone welcome to Simply learn
before we get started I hope the screen
is clearly visible and the audio is fine
if yes please type yes if there is any
issues do let us know in the chat
section so that we can resolve
I am in the code you have to go to the
www.minti.com then here you will find
the code in the top 7995072
will wait for few people to join
good evening
hello everyone welcome to Simply learn
before we get started I hope the screen
is clearly visible and the audio is fine
I need some comments
please type yes if it's fine
okay I think everything is fine hello
everyone and welcome to the quiz today
on web development we would request you
to bear with us as we wait a few minutes
for people to join the stream feel free
to introduce yourself in the comment
section while we wait
to take part in the quiz it's highly
recommended to use your mobile phone to
visit the website
www.minti.com and use the code
7995072 the code is visible on the
screen as well
I'll beat that to take the part in the
quiz it is highly recommended to use
your mobile phone please visit
www.mintry.com and use the code 7995072
foreign
you can also use a different tab or your
own browser to take part in this quiz
but it was live streaming will be
broadcasting the results as soon as the
participant gives the answer so it's
beneficial to have both screen visible
at the same time
once you open the link and input the
code which is 7995072
wait for the quiz to start and be ready
to answer the questions the quicker you
answer the more points you get so think
fast and click fast
so there is enough member here
before we get started with our quiz
let's take a look at the basics of web
development with a small introduction
what is web development
web development is a branch of computer
science that deals with creating and
maintaining a website or a web
application
every website we come across is designed
with a mix of certain methodologies a
website is generally divided into three
parts fronted backend and a database
so who does all these tasks of creating
and maintaining a website
a web developer is the person who is
responsible for all the stuff that goes
around the website a web developer not
only creates the website but also makes
sure that the website should not face
any issues right after the development
moving ahead let's discuss the different
types of website
so web development is basically divided
into three parts front-end web
development backend web development and
full stack web development
let's start with the front-end web
development
front-end web development is the is
branch of web development that consists
of user experience in order to ensure
that the data is presented
understandably and in tires covering the
code created by back-end developers into
a graphical interface without front end
development you would see the
incomprehensive codes on the website or
repair application but thanks to web
developers not programmers can easily
use and comprehend website and web
applications
when you visit Google Apps canvas
Facebook and other websites everything
you see is a result of combination
between web front and web development
and back-end development
you can check out our YouTube videos and
learn about these Technologies
for that
you can go to the skill up website the
link is presented over here also and in
the description box as well find
yourself a course and enroll as soon as
possible
now let's move to the backend
development
backend development is the term used to
describe task carried out while
executing programs on the web instead of
front-end development which focuses on
customer facing services and programs
web developed web and development handle
server-side web development
functionalities integration as well as
activities like designing apis creating
libraries and working with system
components focusing on website
architecture scripting and building code
that communicates between the website
database and the user browser is a part
of backend developers job description
the basics of your page is a programming
language being a bank and developer
requires knowledge of a programming
language and Associated Frameworks which
is not as easy to achieve although many
programming languages are available but
only few are frequently advised for
backend development like JavaScript and
node.js among most difficult programming
languages JavaScript allows you to
explore many ideas and explore and
create truly amazing websites it is
applied in the creation of dynamic and
interactive websites
node.js is a JavaScript framework
created with a real-time pushback
architecture and a single threaded model
used for backend API services in mind
JavaScript may be used to execute on the
server with node.js to get data from a
database a backend developer writes code
that does the relational mapping among
the most popular jvms are MySQL SQL
server mongodb and Oracle database you
must be quite familiar with how they
operate
moving ahead let's discuss full stack
development
full stack development are individuals
create will for developing both the
front and back end of a web development
full stack technology refers to the
total depth of computer system
application the front end of a website
consists of all the functions visible
onto the client the full stack developer
is involved in the entries development
process of an application he creates
both front-end and back-end of a program
while ensuring it has all the necessary
functionalities there is no special
technology related to full stack
development a full stack development
should know about each and every
technology we came across in a front-end
and back-end development there is no
shortcut for this you should know
Technologies like HTML CSS JavaScript
followed by any framework and back-end
Technologies like node.js PHP and many
more additionally a full stack web
developer should know databases apis and
almost everything
you can apply for full stack development
for beginners goes for free click on the
link in the description box below and
search for a full stack developer for
beginners and enroll yourself today or
you can go through our YouTube channel
as well to find the latest technological
videos related to full set development
so these are basic fundamentals of web
development that you need to keep in
mind before we get started
let's wait for a few players to join
so we can start our quiz just a reminder
to join the quiz please visit the
website
www.minti.com and use the code
7995072 to participate like I mentioned
before do try to join the quiz using
your mobile phone to keep your eyes on
the result of the quiz as it progresses
on the live stream
this will help you to stay in touch with
the standing since the top three winners
will receive Amazon vouchers fastest
answer equal higher points so fire away
so soon as will you get the hunch
let's wait for few minutes to people to
join
I think we have
let's wait for a few minutes people are
joining still
let's wait for two three minutes and
then we'll go to go
again I'm telling you that's all we need
to know so you can start our quiz just a
reminder to join the quiz please visit
www.winty.com and use the code
79950722 to participate
let's wait for a few peoples to join
exam
it seems we have enough people now to
take part in the quiz so let's get
started with the first question
what is HTML
the option first is HTML describes the
structure of a website the second option
is HTML is the standard markup language
mainly used to create web pages the
third option is HTML consists of a set
of elements that helps the browser to
view content and the last option is all
of the mentioned above
what is HTML
you have five more seconds to answer
this question
and the times is up
many of them I don't know why I have got
the wrong answer the correct option is
all of them mentioned above
HTML is the standard markup language
mainly used to create web pages HTML
describes the structure and layout of a
web page it consists of series of
elements that help the browser how to
display content easily
let's go to the scoreboard
prachi Agarwal has answered the fastest
in the second and third number
let's go to the second question
which of the following is used to
transmit information on the world wide
web
the options are hppt HTTP and HTTP and
the last one is http
which of the following is used to
transmit information on World Wide Web
we have 15 more seconds to go
don't answer in the comment section on
the video you can come into the
www.minti.com
and the code is visible on the top
and most of them have answered correctly
because it is a easy question HTTP is
used to transmit information on the
worldwide waste
let's go on the scoreboard
and on the leaderboard
let's see if we have answered fastest
and more have answered it fastest
among prachi Agarwal has on the top
let's go to the third question for this
identify the container among the
following
which is the container if you answer
this question before think what is
container body select input or both body
and select
you have 20 more seconds
think identify the containers
which of the following is the container
among these options
you have more five more seconds to join
don't answer in the comment section
and the time is up
most of them have gone wrong
it's both body and select
let's go to the scoreboard
Kamal Sharma please join the quiz on
www.minti.com and the code is visible on
the top of this video you can join the
quiz
and get Amazon vouchers
so the kidney is on the top and we have
nuclear flop artist and the third one is
hey bro
let's move on to the third question
and the fourth question is
which of the following is not a
difference between HTML and xhtml
and the options are cassette in both
HTML and xhtml is text HTML the second
option is tags and attributes are case
insensitive in HTML but not in xhtml and
the third option is special characters
must be escaped using character entities
in sxhtml unlike HTML
you have five more seconds to go
which of the following is not remember
and the time is up
let's see
12 people have corrected the answer and
the 13 have gone wrong
the correct option is cat set in both
HTML and xhtml text HTML
HTML is case sensitive while xhtml is
case insensitive in xhtml special
characters can be escaped using
characters and it is but not in HTML
cache set in HTML is its text HTML
whereas it is application XML Plus xhtml
for xhtml
let's go to the scoreboard
you can still join the quiz
flop artists have correct this answer
fast test
in the top it's Guinea and second flop
artist and Hebrew
let's move on to the third question for
this
which element is used for or styling
HTML5 layout
read the question carefully which
element is used for or styling HTML5
layout and the options are CSS jQuery
JavaScript or PHP
you have 15 more seconds to answer
it's a very simple question which
element is used for or styling HTML5
layout
five more seconds to go
and most of them have give the answer
correct it's CSS for styling HTML5 CA
says that is car scanning style sheet is
used it is style sheet language and
designed to describe the presentation of
its content including layouts color and
fonts CSS can control the layout of
multiple web pages
let's go to the leaderboard and see who
have gone up
in the fastest answer is given by a mole
let's move on to the sixth question
which of the following HTML element is
used for canvas graphics this is also a
very easy question for you
which of the following HTML element is
used for canvas graphics
CSS paid Canvas OR graphic
you have 15 more seconds to go
please don't answer in the comment
section
and the time is up
most of you have given the right answer
it is canvas
CSS
let's move on to the next question
the fastest answer was given by a mole
and on the leaderboard first one is
Guinea flop artist and then hey bro
you can still win the Amazon vouchers
just click fast and get the prices
let's move on to the next question
which of the following element is not
associated with a class attribute
the options are row
thread column cell or rows
which of the following elements is not
associated with a class attribute
read the question carefully and then
answer it
you have 10 more seconds to go
and the time is up
most of you have answered it correctly
it is thread
column cell rows and rows are the
container elements they have a class
attributes with the help of this we can
apply special styling table elements is
also in control style classes text align
and variable align are the style
attributes that align the content of the
table
let's move on to the next question
in the leaderboard
prachi have given the answer correctly
in the fastest
prachi can
win
let's move on to the next question
which of the following has introduced
text list box margin border color and
background properties
first option is HTML second one is PHP
third one is CSS and the fourth one is
Ajax
which of the following has introduced
text list box margin border color and
background properties
you have five more seconds to go
most of you have given the correct
answer it's CSS CSS is a style sheet
language that stands for grass cutting
style sheet CIS has introduced text list
box margin border color and background
properties
let's move on to the leaderboard and see
who are coming up
prachi has again given the answer
Guinea flop artist and Gabriel are on
the top three
please guys give answers and get Amazon
vouchers her top three players will get
500 rupees
Amazon vouchers
let's move on to the next question
what will be the output of the following
CSS codes night
first option is nothing happens an error
occurs
handling becomes dark green or heading
becomes green
this is a very simple question
you have 10 more seconds to go
what will be the output of the following
CSS code snippet
and the time is up
let's see
12 people have given the answer correct
let's
the output of the above code snippet
won't happen as the Declaration syntax
is wrong
the code declaration is H1 color green
which will yield an output in case we
don't write a value in double quotes
so let's move on to the leaderboard
Khushi has given the answer first and
fastest
I think web development is very easy
that's why more people are giving
correct answer but don't worry you can
also come in the top for three
just remember answer quickly you will
get more points for that
let's move on to the next question
which of the following is not the
property of CSS model Box Box model
the options are margin color width or
height
which of the following is not the
property of CSS Box model
the options are margin color width or
height
you have 10 more seconds to go
and the time is up
the color is the property in the
question
CSS Box model includes height width
padding margin and Border or text Fields
have complete support for every property
related to CSS Box model browser relies
on system default systems will display
these widths
let's move on to the leaderboard and see
the positioning
and mole has again answered the question
fastest
among others
let's move on to the next question
what will be the output of the following
CSS code snippet
the options are all span elements will
have a green thick border and a red
outline the second option is all span
elements will have a red border and a
green dotted outline and the third
option is all snap element will have a
outer green dotted border and a inner
red border and the last option is all
snap elements will have an outer red
border and inner green dotted border
and the time is up
let's see
13 people only have given the correct
answer
the correct answer is the C option
the Border property creates the inner
border while the outer line sets the
outer border
so let's move on to the leaderboard
let's see where on the top
again the same names please guys the
fastest do you answer the more points
you will get
let's move on to the next question
which of the following css3 properties
can be used to allow the line breaks
within live Birds
the first option is line break the
second one is line drag third one is
word rack
and the last one is word break
you have 15 more seconds to answer this
question the question is which of the
following css3 properties can be used to
allow line breaks within words the
options are line break line wrap or word
trap or the word break
and the time is up
the correct option is word break word
break property can be used to allow line
breaks within the words
so let's see this leaderboard
I can see new names on the last you can
still back up with them
let's go on to the next question
the third question is
the difference between
JavaScript and Java is
the first question option is there is no
difference the second option is
functions are consisted as fields and
the third option is variables are
specific and the last option is
functions are values and there is no
hard distinction between methods and
Fields
the basic difference between JavaScript
and Java is
three more seconds to answer
and the time is up
most of you have given the correct
answer functions are values that are
hard distinction between methods and
Fields
the basic difference between JavaScript
and Java is that the functions are
values and there is no hard distinction
between methods and Fields
let's move on to the leaderboard
I hope I'll find new names on the top
Kushi has given the correct answer in
the shortest time
let's move on to the next option
question 14.
the kinds of class members are
the options are instance method and
stance field starting method or dynamic
method the second option is fill in
stance instance method class Fields
class methods C option is instance field
non-instance field Dynamic method or
Global methods and the last option is
global method local methods Dynamic
method or static methods
the kinds of class members are a region
and the time is up
16 people have given the correct answer
the four kinds of class members are in
Stan's field in stance method class
field and class methods
let's move on to the leaderboard and see
the positioning
the process you get the answer the more
points you will get
Guinea on the top second one is flop
artist Hebrew and the Khushi and prachi
are close to the three members they can
easily bug up
moving on to the next question
the question number 15
object whose properties are inherited by
the instance of class and properties
whose values are functions behaving like
instance method of class
you have 20 more seconds to answer this
question the options are instant object
the second option is Constructor object
third option is Destructor object and
the last option is prototype object
10 more seconds to answer this in stance
object Constructor object Destructor
object or prototyping object
and the time is up
the correct option is D the properties
of the Prototype object are inherited by
all instances of the class and the
properties whose values are functions
behaving like instance method of the
class
so let's move on to the leaderboard
I think most of the people know web
development that's why their name is
coming on the top but don't worry you
can still win this
let's move on to the next question the
faster you will answer the more points
you will get so give the answer fastest
to get more points
let's move on to the next question
the scope of a function is called
the first option is the functions call
the second option is module function the
third option is modulate function and
the last option is private function the
scope of a function is also called as
the options are functions scope module
function modulate function and the last
option is private function we have five
more seconds to answer this
and the time is up
okay
most of you have given the right answer
it's module function the scope of a
function can be used as a private
namespace for a material
therefore the scope of a function is
called a module function
let's go on to this code word
and the same names on the top but Kushi
and mole can come up in any time
just give your best guys
let's move on to the next question
answer fast to get more points
the method that can be used to create
new properties and also to modify the
attributes of the existing properties is
the options are object dot defined
property function object dot Define
property function
of both object defined property and
object defined properties
give the option correct you have 10 more
seconds to answer
and the time is up
most of you have given the answer
correct the option is both object Define
property and objective object defined
properties function
when used to define new properties any
attribute you
um
did
default to false therefore both object
dot defined property function and object
dot Define property function can be used
to create and modify the attributes
let's move on to the next question
in the leaderboard
and the Khushi came to the third
position
let's see the next question now
the main differences between the
variables declared with where and with
lead is
the option is where is confit to the
particular function but lead is not let
is confide to a particular function but
where is not the C option is where it
defines value based on conditions but
let if does not and the last option is
you have five more seconds to answer
the main differences between the
variable declared with where and with
lit is
the time is up
11 people have given the answer correct
variable declare with where are defined
throughout the enclosing function
variables declared with lead are defined
only within the closest enclosing blocks
and any blocks nested within it of
course
let's move on to the leaderboard
let's see if we have given the correct
answers
hey bro have given the answer
fastest
let's move on to the next question
what will be the output of the following
JavaScript program look at this code
carefully
and give that answer
the options are compilation error
runtime error yes or no
what will be the output of the following
JavaScript program
the fastest you answer the more points
you will get
three more seconds to answer
and the time is up
the correct answer is yes in JavaScript
question mark is called the ternary
operator which is used for closing one
choice from the given two choices it is
used instead of if else statement and
makes the code shorter
so let's move on to the leaderboard and
see who I have given the correct answers
it's one point only
okay let's move on to the next question
what will be the following JavaScript
code snippet
what happens in the following JavaScript
code snippet
the options are
an execution three out
the value of JavaScript are logged or
stored in a particular location or
storage the value of JavaScript for 0 to
9 is displayed in the console and error
occurs in the disk plate
we have five more seconds to answer
read the code correctly and the time is
up
most of you have give the correct answer
the value of J is from 0 to 9 is
displayed in the console
in JavaScript console.log is the
predefined function that accepts the
value as an agreement at the time of
code execution
console.log prints this value in the
argument into the console
let's move on to the next question
before that let's look at the
leaderboard and see the positioning
let's move on to the next question again
what does Rebel stand for
the options are repel stands for
readable print Loop level stands for
research evil program learn or the third
option is read earn Point learn or is it
read a Well Point Loop
you have 10 more seconds to answer
what does Ripple stands for
it's very easy question guys
and the time is up let's see the answer
and most of you have given the correct
answer a is the correct option Ripple
stands for read evil print Loop
let's move on to the leaderboard
and on the top it's flop artist hey bro
and guinea
but it's a very close you can still win
it
let's move on to the next question
always fast answer to get more points in
which language node.js is written it's a
very easy question guys
read the options carefully
first one is Javascript or is it C or is
it C plus plus or coffee script or all
of the above
you have 15 more seconds to answer in
which language is node.js written
you have
another time is up
the correct option is e
all of the above
notice is a cross platform backend
JavaScript runtime environment written
in JavaScript C C plus plus and
coffeescript language
so most of you have given the wrong
answer so let's see who have gone up
you know on the scoreboard
flop artist and Hebrew have given the
answer fastest
let's move on to the next question
what is callback
the options are
the Callback is a technique in which a
method calls back the caller method
second option is the Callback is a
asynchronous evaluatement for the
function and the third option is both of
the above or the D option is none of the
above what is callback is it the
callback is a technique in which a
method calls back the color method or is
it the caller back is a asynchronous
equipment for a function and the time is
up
or most of you have given the answer
wrong the right answer is the Callback
is an asynchronous equivalent for a
function
let's go to the scoreboard
I hope I will see the new names
and the same names
you can still win guys
let's go to the next question again
which of the following types of
application can be built using node.js
the options are web application chat
application restful services and the
last option is all of the above I repeat
which of the following types of
applications can be built using node.js
you have 15 more seconds to answer
the options are web application chat
application restful services and the
last one is all of the above
and the time is up
most of you have given the right answer
all of the above
application can be built by using
node.js
let's move on to the scoreboard
you can still win guys so more questions
are left give answer fastest
okay let's go on to the next question
which of the following is not a benefit
of using modules in Express
which of the following types
of application
benefits of using modules in express it
provides a means of dividing up tasks or
is it provides a means of reuse of
program code or is it it provides a
means of reducing the size of a program
or it provides a means of testing
individuals from parts of the program
and the time is up
10 of you have given the correct answer
and the right answer it
it provides means of reducing the size
of the program is not a benefit of
modules in Express
let's go on to the scoreboard
and in the leaderboard
top three names are
guys
you can still win few more questions are
left
and on the top three are same flop
artists hey bro and guinea
let's move on to the next question
which of the following method can append
specified content to a file
the options are fsfn file function or is
it FS open function or is it FS write
file function or is it none of the above
which of the following method can append
specified content to a file
you have 10 more seconds to answer
give the right answer
and the time is up
most of you have give the correct answer
it is option A
the fs append file function this method
is used to append the specified content
to a file if the file does not exist it
creates the file
so let's move on to the leaderboard and
see
who have given the right answer
you can still win guys
okay good let's move on to the next
question
which of the following is correct way to
get an extension of a file
the options are
FS extend name means dot JS the second
option is path dot extend
namemail.js or is it OS dot EXT name
main function or is it none of the above
the question is which of the following
is the correct way to get an extension
of a file
you have five more seconds to answer
and the time is up
let's see on the scoreboard
the correct answer is path dot extend
name p
Returns the extension for the path from
the last dot to the end string is the
last position of the path if there is no
dot in the last position of the path or
the first character
the dot then Returns the empty string
let's see the scoreboard again
guys
we still have the chance to win
let's go on to the next question again
which of the following is true about
restful web services
the options are
web services based on rest architecture
are known as restful web services the
second option is web services uses HTTP
methods to implement the concept of rest
architecture or is it both of the above
or is it none of the above
the question is which of the following
is true about restful web services
you have three more seconds to answer
guys
and the time is up
14 people have given the correct answer
it's both of the above web services
based on risk architecture are known as
restful web services these web services
uses HTTP methods to implement the
concept of rest architecture
let's move on to the
leaderboard again
and see the positioning again
I hope I will get to see new names on
the top three
the same names
okay guys I think you guys are very good
in web development
let's move on to the next question
how can you install the node body parser
module
this video is on our Channel also guys
the options are npm install body parser
node install body parser or is it
node.js install party power parser or is
it none of the above
I repeat the question how can we install
the node body parser module you have 10
more seconds to answer
and the time is up
the right answer is npm install body
parcel
we use the name install module name
command the install node modules here
the required module is body parser I
have also explained this video on our
YouTube channel you can check out the
video
let's move on to the leaderboard again
and see the positioning
yes guys
okay
let's move on to the last question for
this
the command to install node mon in
node.jss
is it npm install hyphen G node module
node mode or is it node installed G
Globe node mode or is it npm node mod or
is it node node
the G stands for Global guys
you have eight more seconds to answer
the command to install node mode in
node.jss
22 of you have given the correct answer
let's see is there any differences in
the leaderboard
and the winner is flop artist
a new
okay
so with that I believe we have reached
the end of our quiz I hope you enjoyed
this quiz
thank you guys